hey what's going on it's Bill Byrd it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday
October 24th 2022.
[Music]
what's going on how are ya
um
all right I gotta admit something man
like when it comes to my kids toys I am
obsessed
with them not losing
any of the pieces in any of that [ __ ] it
drives me [ __ ] nuts
when you know I see a puzzle and there's
a piece missing or those those little
blocks like the pyramids I'm looking at
it right now I'm like where are the
other [ __ ] pieces that thing over
there is supposed to have three balls it
only has one inside the little house
where the [ __ ] is that that thing over
there had marbles with it where the [ __ ]
are those it drives me up the [ __ ]
wall I don't know why and it's just
something that I've realized that I just
have to let go of
okay the kids get the test stuff they
drag it into other rooms and then when
people go to put it away you know
they're exhausted so they just [ __ ]
throw it in the nearest bin
um whatever you like three months I come
down to the playroom and I empty out all
the bins uh like like that detective
that won't [ __ ] quit on a cold case
and I [ __ ] put everything back
where it should be and there's this one
puzzle
that has it's of an ice cream and the
Cherry is somehow missing and it and it
just it [ __ ]
it ruins my day every time I look at it
I don't know why I should [ __ ] Let It
Go like I just did with like 200 000
pounds of [ __ ] clothes that I've
gotten over the years
um
Jesus Christ you would think I was
moving a [ __ ] dead body out of my
house the amount of garbage bags so I
got some [ __ ] that I'm selling and then
I found this place where I can donate it
because I didn't want to just you know
bring it over to Goodwill where I just
feel like the people over there people
are just dumping this [ __ ] off onto them
where they feel like oh yeah good I
didn't throw it out they make good will
do it you know
so
um
anyway yeah and the reason why I use
that garbage bag taking a body out of
the house is
you know it's kind of no secret it's
almost like a hack premise at this point
that women like to watch murder shows
before they go to bed and True Crime and
all of that
uh uh mclaff she watched one the other
night
that was
they're all disturbing but this one was
just extra disturbing and what killed me
was she ends up falling asleep to it
like somebody's reading her like a
[ __ ] bedtime story and I am awake
watching this [ __ ] it was this murder
that happened in Ohio
this guy was like six foot four
everybody loves him great guy amazing
father incredible relationship with his
son
and I'm watching this thing he starts
dating this jealous woman you know where
this is going right
so what happens when you date somebody
jealous what ends up happening they
smother you and at one point you gotta
[ __ ] leave so they think he broke up
with her
and uh here's one that I learned all
right
if you break up with somebody jealous if
you're not moving change your locks
so this woman had a key and went in
there and when the guy was sleeping she
came in and she shot him in the head
all right and then she cut up his body
and dumped it off on the Highway 75 in
three different areas
complete [ __ ]
lunatic and watching the family they're
heartbroken
the guy's mother was was getting treated
for cancer she was so upset she stopped
getting treated for cancer she basically
killed her too
and the one
feeling of satisfaction you could
possibly get is that they're going to
arrest this psycho they're going to
charge her and then she's going to rot
in jail for the rest of her life that
didn't happen she somehow
made bail or whatever they did no they
did not even bail they didn't have
enough to hold her when they first
brought her in but she knew that it was
a matter of time
and she [ __ ] took off
and they can't [ __ ] find her and
they've been calling
her family and they're just like nope I
haven't seen her and they just clearly
think that they're helping her and she's
just out there
and then they're just like and that's
where we are right now
good night
have a nice night
um
yeah so I don't I don't know I'm
actually going to like try and follow
that case
you know I I just don't I I don't know I
guess I understood the good thing about
that one is they put her face out there
and everything so maybe she'll be caught
I guess that that was like the good one
but I just don't understand like why
you know
you're watching those things it's like
that's your entertainment for the
evening the worst [ __ ] thing that
could possibly happen to another family
and you're just sitting there eating
popcorn no I used to a joke about that
when like that Michael Jackson [ __ ] came
out and someone's like you see a Michael
Jackson documentary and I was like no I
didn't like oh you gotta see it
it's like dude my entertainment for the
evening is not going to be uh alleged
pedophilia testimony
you know I'm gonna watch Dumb and Dumber
I
I want to get away from the problems of
the world
uh
uh speaking of problems
I gotta tip my cap to Major League
Baseball
the way that they handled the the the
the cheating scandal of the Houston
Astros
taking a nod from the NBA
on how when it's truly
like a
the highest level of cheating
um
how they just put like a gag order on
everybody and everybody just shuts up
about it and like if you watch the
Astros against the Yankees you would
never if you were like an astronaut are
you a [ __ ] Tom Hanks out at Sea with
the soccer ball you would never know you
would have no [ __ ] idea that these
people fixed a [ __ ] World Series
and that's the one thing that I I kind
of hit me the whole time I'm watching it
as a Patriots fan who still has to
listen to [ __ ] about the flight gate and
Spygate
I'm like
wow and these other people have to
listen to [ __ ] about a guy who had like
a cork bat or some [ __ ] why does this
[ __ ] immediately go away
where this thing was like you know
not like a one-game thing this was like
a season-long thing and they won a
championship literally a team that
should have won the World Series didn't
because the Astros were cheating every
[ __ ] home game
giving themselves an advantage that they
won the World Series now why
would I still be hearing about
deflategate even by ESPN and all of that
[ __ ]
right why would ESPN continue with
stories saying we filmed the [ __ ]
Rams when we didn't and then when they
found out it was a [ __ ] lie why would
they retract that statement at two in
the [ __ ] month because they don't
give a [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] they're just
about the [ __ ] money okay and when
it's just Ticky Tech you know he said
she said horseshit
they're allowed to talk about it
everybody talks about it everybody jokes
about it but when it's actual real
cheating
like Tim Donahue fixing NBA games like
the Sacramento Kings getting [ __ ] out
of a championship like the Lakers having
that banner up on their [ __ ]
Arena
that shouldn't be there
everybody shuts the [ __ ] up because when
there's cheating going on at that level
it [ __ ] with the entire Integrity of
the game
the entire Integrity of the game now
you're [ __ ] with everybody's money
the other 29 teams are going to look the
other way because if the entire league
looks like it's it's not on the up and
up everybody's going to lose so all the
teams shut the [ __ ] up all the players
shut the [ __ ] up the coaches the owners
the entire league shuts the [ __ ] up and
then furthermore the sports writers the
news networks they all shut the [ __ ] up
the broadcasters everybody shuts the
[ __ ] up just shut up don't talk about it
you know just let it go away
like what the [ __ ] Houston Astros did
is on the same level of the Chicago
Black Sox
in my whole lifetime they were known as
the black socks they never called them
the White Sox so my whole time growing
up I thought that they were some defunct
MLB team you know that went under
because they cheated or maybe during the
Depression or World War II they got
combined with another team and never
brought them back or they moved
it wasn't until I was in my 40s or
something I finally found out that they
were the [ __ ] White Sox
so that's my [ __ ]
right there
okay
I can now
let go of all this crap when people say
the Patriots are cheaters and so it's
like oh I get it I get it this is just
Ticky Tech horseshit that's why you're
still talking about it that's why the
media still talks about it and all of
that [ __ ] I get it because it was
[ __ ] a cork bat Gaylord Perry with
mayonnaise on his [ __ ] t-shirt it's
Jersey whatever that's all [ __ ] ahaha
whatever blah blah but when you really
[ __ ] cheat it's amazing when you
really [ __ ] cheat everybody shuts the
[ __ ] up they go Epstein Island on it
they [ __ ] they [ __ ] nail one one
guy two people they [ __ ] whack them
and then everybody else that was
involved gets to [ __ ] skate everybody
that went to Epstein Island what about
that right that's a great question what
about all of those [ __ ] people right
how come they don't bring them up
it's too big
it's too big it [ __ ] with the Integrity
of the game
the Houston Astros are the Epstein
Island
[Music]
of Major League Baseball that's it they
even even the owner of the team got to
act like he didn't know what was going
on
I was joking with the buddy of mine like
that's your [ __ ] team they're cutting
a [ __ ] you know they got a camera out
in center field
you don't see them cutting a [ __ ]
hole in the goddamn wall out there that
would be like you coming home to your
own house and and not realizing that
somebody remodeled one of your bathrooms
um
I don't know so that's the deal man
that's and that's why I actually rooted
for the first time in my life I rooted
for the [ __ ] New York Yankees in that
series
because at no point
were they saying that the Houston Astros
need to show the world the world meaning
just Baseball fans in the United States
but we'll call it the world
they need to show that they can win a
championship
without cheating so severely that
everybody in the league when they find
out about it can only talk about it for
two weeks before everybody has to shut
the [ __ ] up
um
you know what's funny when the Astros
got busted
I actually laughed
and I looked at it like well you know
the Red Sox and Yankees were Fielding
these 200 million dollar roided up free
agent teams that wasn't exactly fair
either right
but
you know
the steroid scan will happen all those
guys got busted and blah blah and they
still carry that [ __ ]
like all of those guys like you never
see Mac McGuire anymore Sammy Sosa is
trying to become a white guy I mean the
whole [ __ ]
you know
all of those [ __ ] people carry that
now
you know and people can't get in the
Hall of Fame Barry Bonds can't get in
Clemens can't get in they go because
that's just like individual [ __ ]
but when it's actually at like a team
level
and it affects the championship it's
amazing they just everybody's like well
that's gonna [ __ ] with the Integrity of
the game the Integrity of the league and
the real thing is going to [ __ ] with all
of our money
so then it just goes away so
congratulations to the Houston Astros
you cheating pieces of [ __ ] not only did
you cheat your way to a [ __ ] world
series title not only do they count it
it's going to be forgotten because
nobody's going to talk about it
and this is the deal sports fans
for the most part are just like anybody
else where all they're going to do is
talk about what's being said on TV so
all they so these [ __ ] [ __ ] know
if we don't talk about it they'll stop
talking about it and they'll forget
about it and they'll that we won't have
to risk them being like I'm not [ __ ]
watching that game because it's fixed
um
yeah so which brings me to the
Philadelphia Phillies everybody your
Philadelphia Phillies
looking to win their first title in I
want to say 14 years
um
oh God why can't I remember that Bryce
Harper
Bryce [ __ ] Harper just took that
series over
you know what's weird about that guy he
went from a team that played red and
white
uniforms to a team that plays red and
white uniforms and I kind of forget
that uh you know he was traded in a way
and I know that all the Nationals
fans when they won the World Series were
all [ __ ]
yelling at Bryce harp and [ __ ] you man
see you with a problem
and I was thinking to myself was he
really the pro I don't like
were you just mad that he left and
you're happy that you went on and won
something without him because that
[ __ ] guy just took over that Series
so now I uh
it's now rooting for the Phillies I mean
like I don't want the Astros
to win again now that I give a [ __ ]
about the Astros but I just it just bugs
me
that they're not getting the [ __ ] that
they [ __ ] deserve that it's it was
just like oh you know let me [ __ ]
Altuve with a guy have like two hits the
whole [ __ ] series guys [ __ ] anemic
at the plate
that is wide open to be like gee when
you don't know what pitch is coming all
of a sudden your batting average goes
down by [ __ ] 300 points right can't
say that
can't [ __ ] say that
hahaha
so
it is funny though I did get like um
you know that Philly show I had all
those years ago I mean it's coming up on
20 years ago that stupid show that I had
where I went off on the crowd because
they were going off on me and to this
day anytime a Philadelphia team does
something I still get a couple of tweets
it's amazing
it's amazing you would think that Jim
irsay said something about that show
like somebody tweeted at me saying was
just basically suggesting
that I would be upset that the
Philadelphia Phillies could win a World
Series and
I kind of laughed I was going to write
the guy back and I was just like nah I
don't want to do that because
the truth is actually more hurtful
[Music]
[Laughter]
which is I've never given a [ __ ]
about Philadelphia teams not in like a
bad way it's just
they're not in our conference
like the Philadelphia Phillies have been
around since the 1880s the Red Sox I
don't know what our deal is we became
the Red Sox in the early 1900s we were
something else in the 1800s
the Phillies and the Red Sox have never
played a a game that mattered
in 140 years there's there's nothing
there
well so they got
they got the Eagles who we played in a
Super Bowl and lost to but the year
before that we won the Super Bowl in the
year after that we won the Super Bowl so
that's like the Aaron Boone Factor like
when Yankee fans would bring up Aaron
Boone
like it was going to hurt it was like
dude it didn't have time
to take root like those giant losses
took root because
that that was that time when we just
didn't we didn't win for like we went
from like what like oh three or oh four
to like 20 feels like a 10-year period
so those things had time to take root
where like you know if you won the Super
Bowl and then you lost the Super Bowl
and you won the Super Bowl
you don't give a [ __ ] or like Aaron
Boone hits that home run dude that was
[ __ ] devastating for 11 months
and then we were down O3 came back won
it and won the whole [ __ ] thing and
then it just like disappeared Bucky Dent
Bill Buckner that [ __ ]
didn't marinate that just soaked into
the [ __ ] floorboards I mean that hung
around for [ __ ] 30 years or whatever
so
um
and then who else they got the Flyers
actually he's like the Flyers when I was
growing up because I like that they you
know you know Ron Hextall running out of
the [ __ ] skating out of the the goal
I never hated any of those people you
know the only team I ever hated was the
Sixers in the early 80s because they
were in competition with the Celtics so
hate to break it to you Philly fans I I
don't give a [ __ ] I actually now love
the early 80s 76ers the same way I now
love
the showtime Lakers that I hated now I
look back I'm like man those [ __ ]
guys were amazing
um
and that was great basketball so for the
record these are the teams that I hate
all right in hockey I hate the Montreal
Canadiens
in basketball I hate the Los Angeles
Lakers in baseball I hate the New York
Yankees in football I don't hate anybody
for the longest time it was the Colts
for a minute
it was the Seahawks
uh um and for a second I started to hate
the Chiefs
and uh
yeah and that's kind of it I used to
hate the Cults when you know as ursay
and Peyton Manning I hated that all that
[ __ ]
I used to hate the Dolphins I don't
[ __ ] hate anybody right now
[Laughter]
um yeah we want a bunch of titles we're
rebuilding
I'm happy for the bills I really enjoyed
that game last night with the Dolphins
and the Steelers two up and coming teams
I loved how they they gave the nod
to the 72 dolphins and had the old logo
in the end zone I mean I was right out
of NFL films I will have to say though
you know
it's getting a little Annoying with the
dolphins with that undefeated season
still talking about that because now
it's like all right
so
when they went undefeated 17-0 was the
benchmark
right
then the Patriots go 18-0 but there's
still one more game and they lose to the
Giants so they go 18-1
so the Dolphins still hold on to it so
I'm like all right you know the Dolphins
did go into the next season and I know
that they won like five or six games
continued on the streak so but they
weren't playoff games so you can't
really count those but I was like all
right you know
okay I guess I can live with that but
now this like
there's 17 regular season games so you
basically you have to duplicate what the
Dolphins did
and then go to the playoffs playoffs and
try to win three games so now you have
to go 20-0 to say you're better than a
17-0 team like like at what point is it
kind of like all right
this is like one of those like you know
a 19 [ __ ] whatever Hank Greenberg had
a 190 RBIs no one has ever done it since
evidently Hank Greenberg is one of the
is the greatest offensive baseball
player of all time no one has ever come
Barry Bonds cannot touch this man
um I know what you're thinking well Bill
you're talking about cheating what about
Barry Bonds Barry Bonds as I've always
said is was a victim of the steroid era
because he was the best guy and then a
bunch of people cheated and all of a
sudden the president was calling them
congratulating them so then he said oh
yeah well here's me on steroids here's
73 home runs and then everybody's like
oh what the [ __ ]
[Music]
there's another one that was stupid
was the Lance Armstrong
everybody in that entire [ __ ] race
was drugging and got caught and all the
[ __ ] that run the race were making all
this money is landscap winning the race
and then when they finally they froze
his [ __ ] piss or whatever and then
years later I had the test that they
needed to figure out that he was dope
and they were all like what the [ __ ]
this isn't what this Sport's about and
yada yada yada yada
um
but they all kept their money all the
money that they made off of them
and then I believe
uh uh the Department of Justice tried to
take Lance Armstrong's money I believe
but they didn't try to take it I guess
because those other guys were from
France
I don't know it's all [ __ ] all I
know is that the Astros
cheated in baseball on a level
that has not been seen since the 1919
Chicago White Sox and it was not and
that was like [ __ ] four or five years
ago and it was not brought up once and I
think it's [ __ ] [ __ ] okay now
here's the other side
I don't even know how many people are
left from that [ __ ] team that did
that [ __ ] the amount the way the teams
turn over and all this but this if they
win it this should be considered
their first World Series
right am I crazy
you know what sucks in all of this is I
love Dusty Baker
um whatever there you go this is my
little [ __ ] Sports rant so
you know when it comes to like pumping
crowd noise in where the Indianapolis
Colts are the best in the business of
doing that like all of that [ __ ] they
will look the other way
unless you win a title and then they'll
give you [ __ ] about it if they if the
media
if the media is giving you [ __ ] about it
then it's sort of ticky tack [ __ ]
however
Jesus Christ
[ __ ] dry throat here
sorry I had to go [ __ ] hack one up
there
um anyway yeah if you're still if your
team got caught cheating and people are
still giving you [ __ ] about it it's
Ticky tack [ __ ] all right but if your
team got caught cheating
and everybody shuts up about it
immediately there's a quick Swift
investigation there's a couple two three
people that's the bad guy that's bad guy
that's bad guy and that's it nothing to
say
is he here and even the media shuts the
[ __ ] up that means that you cheated on a
Chicago White Sox Houston Astro [ __ ]
level
that is that's just my takeaway and I'm
not saying I'm right I might be wrong
and you guys can take all this with the
grain of salt you can be like oh he's
just a Patriots fan of yada yada yada
yada all I know all I'm saying is this
is that the Astros should be getting at
least 15 years of [ __ ] over this one
if the math is the same with what I've
been experiencing as a Patriots fan this
should be going on
for a long long [ __ ] time it isn't
just some horseshit
that's a [ __ ] drug addicted owner
[ __ ] made up
but I don't know what are you gonna do
anyway so good luck to both teams at the
Astros win I will be happy for uh for
Dusty Baker but um I will always bring
up them I will always say that they only
have one one championship
and if the Phillies win you know that's
great too you know
um
it'd be good the Bryce Harper story
would be great where then he could be
like [ __ ] you
to uh the Nationals because he put that
team on his back
in uh the NLCS so we shall see
um
anyway plowing ahead here uh
oh I gotta play you guys something that
I just you know for the longest time
like you know I've always liked the band
Journey right but I never for whatever
reason I just never
bought any of their [ __ ] in the 80s
because I was just like I was in the
middle man and you know Journey had
keyboards and even though I secretly
liked them I can't have that cassette
tape in my collection
um so
I downloaded
that that album 1988 1981 sorry the
Escape album
and dude I gotta tell you Steve Perry
is like I don't know like one of one of
the most underrated unbelievable like
everybody always has an unbelievable
voice but like this [ __ ] guy
I got the album because you know I'm a
Steve Smith fan
the drummer and I just want you know
he's got all these drum parts for these
great drum parts for these songs that
are actually really like
you know
not just straight ahead they really got
all these little nuances to him and
everything and they still hit songs
which I think is like a really high
level of musicianship that you can
actually have a hit song a pop song
and still have musicians listening going
oh what the [ __ ] was that oh that's cool
um so I was like well you know there's
all these other tracks that Steve Smith
played on
and I never even listened to him let me
uh
let me listen to some of these uh you
know deep cuts of Journey so here's a
song
I'm listening to it's called lay it down
it's the seventh track so it's on the
back side of the album back in the day
off their escaped album
and Steve Perry does this [ __ ] run
right
you gotta hear this [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
that's track seven
some throw away [ __ ] to fill out the
album do you [ __ ] hear that
um
it's funny I can't even talk today for
whatever reason oh my god I've opened my
daughter's sick right now she's been
coughing all night I think I'm starting
to get it oh Jesus I'm getting sick here
um
anyway [ __ ] Steve Perry
I was listening to that you know because
I've been going back to the gym finally
trying to drop all this weight I put on
during covet and directing this movie
and I just been on the elliptical and um
you know so I just put on that Journey
up and I'm listening to it and you know
by this seventh song you know I'm just
sort of in the zone and I'm not
listening and all of a sudden Steve
Perry does that run and I was just like
the [ __ ] was that
and I rewound it and the second time I
listened to it all the hair on my arms
stood up
Jesus Christ what a [ __ ] voice
my God
um
so check that one out if you want to
have a nice a deep cut of [ __ ]
Journey the song's called lay it down
off of the Escape album 1981
um
yeah I almost fell off the elliptical
when I heard that
I think one of the as far as like
like you know people always talk about
Robert Plant's little run there this is
just white guy [ __ ] rock singers by
the way okay I know this you know
somebody in your local church that
probably can blow both of them away but
I'm just saying right some [ __ ] uh
people always bring up that run that uh
Robert Plant does in Cashmere
and um
as great as that is
like he can't even [ __ ] with Steve Perry
I don't think
um you might like Led Zeppelin's music
bet or whatever but just as far as vocal
power and all of that why can't I just
say Steve Perry is good why do you gotta
like [ __ ] bring because someone else
has to go down down that's how it works
um
anyway so uh
and I also kind of wanted to go
backwards with that band because I
remember seeing a long time ago how uh
before Steve Perry got in the group
you know it was much more of a a rock
band
where when Steve got there they got more
into like the power ballads and stuff so
those sort of that great push-pull in
there because Neil Shawn was like this
[ __ ] insane guitar player
but then Steve Perry had this amazing
voice and was also sort of like a Motown
guy
and was going more in that direction I
guess I'm probably [ __ ] this whole
story up because I'm kind of getting
into the history of that band but if you
go I wanted to go backward to see like
where that band was because I remember
watching the Behind the Music
and
those guys sort of fighting the
direction that Steve Perry was bringing
him in and there was some ballad song
that he wanted to do and they have the
band was like I don't know about this
then they did it live and all the chicks
went nuts and everybody had their
lighters up and they're like oh all
right
I guess this [ __ ] works
um
anyway uh Monday Night Football tonight
the [ __ ] New England Patriots my
Patriots the deflategate Spy gate
that'll never [ __ ] end Patriots
um
and by the way the Houston Astros are in
the World Series
anything else nope nothing else
um
we are playing the Chicago Bears I put
money on them I didn't have the nerve to
look at my bets this week I took the
lines they got smoked and there was
somebody else of the two games I could
remember that I picked both of them were
losses so I think I'm getting my ass
kicked this year I don't [ __ ] I'm I'm
uh what do you want from me how about
you Kansas City Chiefs
you know got no respect at the beginning
of the Season didn't look good you know
through September and all of a sudden
now they're starting to put it together
Patrick Mahomes getting comfortable all
of a sudden other people getting other
touches we'll say that number 17 guy I
don't know any of the [ __ ] names
um all of a sudden they're putting it
together
and all of this talk
about the Sand Diego
superchargers it's looking like it's
still going to be Kansas City and and
Russell Wilson going to Denver all of
this talk meaning all of the [ __ ] that I
said turns out let's see the NFL
standings right now NFL standings
I know Justin Herbert was hurt and he's
kind of been like bruised rib guy for a
while here
all right
um
wait a minute the Jets are five and two
they're that good I thought they were
like [ __ ]
I don't know what they were
this whole season is just flying past me
Chiefs first place five and two charges
four and three they Raiders Paul verzi's
great pick this week two and four the
Broncos two and five
four and three four oh I took the
Bengals yesterday too no I didn't I took
whoever the [ __ ] they were playing
oh the Falcons I finally bought in with
the Falcons going like you know what
they got a good quarterback they [ __ ]
you know
they're scoring points and then I ended
up realizing that you know what the
Falcons and the Colts are the exact same
team in that you don't know who the
[ __ ] gonna show up
oh the Eagles are still undefeated nice
I love it
I hope they [ __ ] go 20-0 so I don't
have to [ __ ] hear about it well then
they'll eat then Eagles fans will never
shut up about it
um
[Music]
laughs
you know every once in a while I say
something even too [ __ ] up for this
podcast
um
anyway uh plowing ahead here
wait let me see what the Falcons did did
I lose every [ __ ] bet this week
Falcon score
and you you know what you got what
that's what the [ __ ] I get that's what I
get for betting on a [ __ ]
organization that was up by [ __ ] 200
points at halftime at a Super Bowl and
still couldn't put it away you know what
I deserved that and I bet on the lines
what the [ __ ] am I doing betting on the
Lions the lions are a family-owned
business they're like in their fourth
generation none of them know anything
about football that's just they're not
going to walk away from the a billion
dollar business inheritance so they're
all [ __ ] hanging around the only guy
who knew what the [ __ ] he was doing that
organization was the original guy that
bought it when he had Bobby Lane and
they haven't won ever since then and
here I am put my hard-earned [ __ ] joke
money on that [ __ ] up organization
about the Patriots tonight too let's see
if I can go 0 and 4. I don't remember
who uh
who the last one was
um did you guys see that weird
commercial where that guy was trying to
like he owed his friend money and he was
trying to pay him back but he was trying
to give him cash and the guy
categorically refused to take the cash
and he wanted him to use this Banking
App instead
I mean you want to talk about cheat and
[ __ ] you think the Astros are bad if
you look at the banking system
throughout [ __ ] history of this
country
all right
how cash
used to reprim represent gold you could
actually bring the paper down and if you
said I want the gold for this paper they
would give you the gold and then they
took us off the gold standard
and then they were then they would then
they were they took over a [ __ ] money
supply they they took oh they they they
took us off the gold standard and then
once they took us out to Gold Standard
they were allowed to print more money
than they had gold so then it became
[ __ ] meaningless this is your [ __ ]
inflation all right this has nothing to
do with red or blue ties it's these
[ __ ] Banker [ __ ] none of whom can
fight
you know what I mean none of these
people know how to [ __ ] fight
they did this suit and tie people with
[ __ ] pencils and they got their foot
in the back of all of our [ __ ] necks
and they're showing this [ __ ] on TV and
that one [ __ ] person is gonna say a
goddamn thing about oh I'm I shouldn't
take the cash I should at least take the
[ __ ] paper that people still believe
in that has nothing behind it
I just need to take the next step and
now ref ooh cash is bad
send it directly to my account you know
any 10 years from now put it put it on
my [ __ ] microchip
you know the only thing I am happy about
that coveted [ __ ] is with the amount of
people that push back on on uh listening
to doctors I really hope those same
people will push back
with microchipping I doubt it though
because they'll somehow tie it into
America
and killing people who aren't white and
then they'll get behind it
Oh Boy Bill let's let's [ __ ] stay out
of that [ __ ] [ __ ] all right let's do
some reads here indochino
finding the perfect suit is impossible
but finding a suit that's perfect for
you is simple thanks to indochino choose
your favorite Fabric and customize every
detail to find the look that's perfect
for you submit your measurements online
or get measured in a store for custom
for a custom made for you fit and an
incredible price yeah and an incredible
price and here's the thing about a
[ __ ] suit nobody knows if it's
expensive
they don't just pick a really cool
[ __ ] pattern you're gonna look
different I literally saw that at a
wedding I was at a wedding I spent a
bunch of money on a [ __ ] suit and and
every and I walked up and said like man
I love that suit even he paid like
[ __ ] 200 for it it's like an
indochino [ __ ] suit
they look great look like a million
bucks
anyway every indochino suit is made just
for you it's a tailored experience at a
great price shop they're made for you
suits starting is 449 and premium fitted
suits at just 89 you can fine tune every
detail lapels Linings Monograms and more
get a premium personalized wardrobe
without spending a fortune shop Custom
fitted suits casual wear outerwear and
more they're always adding new designs
and fabric options like their latest
fall collection ready to elevate your
look further indochino lets you fit make
let you make any suit a tuxedo design
your perfect suit with indochino to get
fifty dollars off any purchase of 399 or
more use promo code Bird indochino.com
that's
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code Burr
uh look who it is everybody it's all zip
you know in the latest news Halloween is
expected to be epic this year so party
supply stores had to hire tens of
thousands of workers they needed
everyone from supervisors to stalkers to
keep up with the sales of fake blood
fangs and other frightening costumes and
accessories sounds like a dreadful task
which is why party supply stores and
business owners businesses of all sizes
use zip
[Music]
earth.com zip recruiter uses its
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates up with your job
then they can easily review these for
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply only the hotties
additional zippers
has complete has a complete Suite of
tools that makes it easier to filter
review and rate your candidates in fact
four to five employers who post on zip
get a quality candidate within the first
day hiring doesn't have to be scary just
go to this exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free that's
ziprecruiter.com once again that's it
dot com slash Burr b-u-r-r sip
recruiter.com
the smartest way to hire I thought that
they're going to have that they didn't
have this week
um oh look who it is everybody it's
policy genius
policy genius you know we all hope we
never need life insurance but mortgage
payments child care and other expenses
don't disappear when you're gone yeah
they don't because those unforgiving
Banker [ __ ] uh life insurance though uh
through your workplace may not offer
enough protection for your family's
needs and it won't follow you if you
leave your job policy genius was built
to modernize the life insurance industry
their technology makes us easy to
compare life insurance quotes from top
companies like AIG you know AIG is a top
company the too big to fail guys
and Prudential in just a few clicks to
find your lowest prices AIG the Houston
Astros of bankers
[Laughter]
and policy genius has licensed agents
who can help you find options that offer
coverage in as little as a week and
avoid unnecessary medical exams they're
not they're not in incentivized to
recommend one Insurance insurer over
another so you can trust their guidance
there are no added fees and your
personal information is private no
wonder they have thousands of five star
reviews on Google and trustpilot your
loved ones deserve a financial safety
net you deserve a smarter way to buy it
head to policygenius.com or click on the
links to describe uh in the description
to get your free life insurance quotes
and see how much you could save that's
policygenius.com if you're a [ __ ] like
me genius is spelled g-e-n-i-u-s
all right uh lastly but not leastly
Roman
uh 42 almost half I love that 42 percent
is not almost half if you're talking
about money
you owe me hat you owe me 50
listen let this this thing cost a
hundred bucks you owe me 50. well here's
42.
what is the other eight bio I was almost
there
do you guys notice how long it took me
to figure out like that little Panic
math panic I just had in my head as I
try to come up with an example let's
start over again Roman everybody 42
percent almost half of men experience
moderate to extensive hair loss in their
lifetime
I think I'm in the extensive part uh
there are options available to help stop
balding in its tracks the sooner a
person starts treatment for hair loss
the easier it is to keep the hair they
have Roman offers clinically proven
medication to help treat hair loss all
from the comfort and privacy of your
home getting started is simple complete
a free online visit then a U.S licensed
health care professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate Roman ships it
directly to you in a discrete package
with free two-day shipping treatment
starts just twenty dollars per month on
a quarterly plan right now Roman has a
special offer for our listeners use this
link to get 20 off your first order just
go to get roman.com today that's get
roman.com for twenty percent off
um there you go all right
now here we are we're into the questions
for the week
the part where everybody writes in
all right what do we got here uh siestas
dear Billy beatballs I gotta be honest
with you I love beets
all right but you know what's funny
about Beats when you get older you got
you and your brain isn't as sharp as it
used to be is if you have a beet salad
for lunch the next day when you take a
dump you're gonna think you're [ __ ]
you have you have ass cancer
you know you oh my God I'm bleeding from
my ass and then you gotta like go
through a pain oh wait wait I had a beet
salad I forgot
um
all right dear Billy beet balls I'm a 45
year old living in Tijuana big fan of
your comedy and love the way your mind
works you [ __ ] psycho I gotta do a
showdown in Mexico I got a couple
buddies and I've done some shows down
there and they said I got people down
there like my stuff
um I'm thinking maybe next year I do a
show in Mexico City the same weekend as
the F1 race
uh down there that'd be pretty cool
you know little two for one there uh
anyway anyways he says my parents are
original okay so last week I talked
about taking naps
which I already feel like I could do at
eight o'clock in the morning here
um
and how around the world there's so many
of these places that they shut down in
the afternoon and everybody goes home
and takes a nap at how great it is and I
asked if there was anybody from Mexico
or one of these Siesta countries if you
could tell me if that's actually true so
this guy says anyways my parents are
originally from a little town outside of
Guadalajara Mexico and siestas are still
being honored or kept business owners
close for a couple hours to go home and
have their midday meals or whatever even
in the big city it's not uncommon to
find clothes shop during the day that's
my report you bald-headed [ __ ]
foreign
so I guess yeah you can go home and have
a meal or like take a nap that is
[ __ ] amazing
that is [ __ ] amazing we got to get
back to that
do you think you guys think there's any
way to ever get out from underneath
these corporate [ __ ] lunatics
and the people that run them you know I
just was just so amazing if you just be
like a [ __ ] human being again
you know and like there was something
behind the money and everybody wasn't
trying to [ __ ] everybody in a business
deal and everybody just sort of chilled
and stop trying to win
and rather just just sort of like lived
can you imagine if you could just come
home
you know see your wife or whatever she
doesn't have to work if she doesn't want
to like the way it was back in the day
and for all you feminists out there hey
if you want to go out there and [ __ ]
grind every day I'll stay home
I'll stay home and I'll [ __ ] you know
I'll take the kids out
get some grilled cheese sandwiches come
home and watch the [ __ ] card sharks
or whatever uh Siesta myth here's
another one hey Bill
last week you asked if folks believed
the Siesta works I refer to a story a
carpenter named Russell told me when I
worked on his crew a few years ago in
North Carolina referring to the first
time he hired an all Hispanic crew
southern accent well I figured I'd try
them out they showed up that first
morning
and went at it heart then about 10
o'clock
they started shutting tools down and
laying down on the floor and going to
sleep I was running yeah I was running
around yelling for him to get up the
hell y'all doing we gotta work
uh
uh they said uh no sir we rest now and
just kept laying there
and I thought oh God damn it kick
sawdust into the air well here in about
20 minutes
they got up and hammered down again till
about two o'clock then went down again
for another 20 minute nap yeah what's
wrong with that
well here come about 5 30 or so I was
worn out ready to shut her down and head
to the house told him to do the same
they said no sir we work till eight
o'clock Russell said they outworked the
hell out of me
hell they're about day three I started
Siesta siestaing with them well I should
have been doing the southern accent hey
they outworked the hell out of me Hill
about day three I started csding with
them
well that's amazing but I don't know
work till eight
uh there's just no winning you know what
God doesn't give a [ __ ] he just doesn't
give a [ __ ] I I just really just refuse
to believe that there's a [ __ ] higher
power that gives a [ __ ] I'll go with the
[ __ ] that he made us all but he doesn't
give a [ __ ] uh moralist story [ __ ] works
if you look back at human behavior
before the modern clock and the
Industrial Revolution sleeping all night
wasn't a normal wasn't a normalized even
now folks get tired mid-morning early
morning and wake up at 2 A.M
to [ __ ] each other
what it's not so much insomnia we just
don't listen to our bodies and drum it
out with caffeine and other stimulants
oh yeah that is true uh I hope that
wasn't too complicated to read aloud
yeah as you spell insomnia with a
[ __ ] a
uh we publicly educated we publicly
educated gotta stick together oh then he
shits on himself yeah all right I get it
we would have been joking around in
class getting in trouble my apologies
um
okay [ __ ] ways to protest
hey Bill piggy backing off last week's
okay hey Bill piggybacking I thought it
was gonna be some long nickname hey Bill
pigging back piggybacking off last
week's email about the soup throwing
[ __ ] I'd like to say that blocking
traffic is the absolute most pointless
and selfish way
to protest anything you also forgot
ineffective
because I don't care what you're
protesting the second you block traffic
the amount of people I guess they they
do it because they want to get publicity
uh it's still a stupid thing to do uh
keeping people from getting to work or
picking up their kids is [ __ ] stupid
I'm not going to read
you dumb sign
you know what I love you guys you guys
are just as dumb as I'm not going to
read you dumb sign not your dumb sign
you dumb sign I have to pick up my kids
so he's not standing outside the school
by himself I have to get to my job or
I'll get fired and I can't feed my kid
uh these are the things that go through
my head yeah can you imagine if they
ever stopped traffic and there was
somebody like you know in labor or
something like that and God forbid
something horrible happened
that's on the horizon I'm never reading
your [ __ ] sign have I said that yet
even if I did read your dumb [ __ ]
sign
there's nothing I can do about
literally anyone's problems I'm trying
to stay afloat in my own goddamn life
you know you just in a very profound way
described why
the system runs the way it does
and why they grind everybody down to
nothing is because you're so busy trying
to stay afloat you don't have time to
help out your fellow men
um all right this is getting depressing
all right evil Farms
all right Jesus Christ you guys are
going dark this week uh dear BBC
uh Bill Burr comedian
uh congrats on taking your career to
another level well I didn't realize I
did that
um the guy says your recent Red Rock
show has gone to another level well
thank you very much
according to the critics I missed the
Mark again
I hope I keep missing the mark because
missing the mark translates to wonderful
ticket sales a few weeks ago you
responded to a viewer's comments about
plastic in the ocean one of your
responses was to eat farmed salmon
versus eated wild salmon sorry to tell
you that farm salmon is the greatest
factor destroying wild salmon
and also is full of drugs my home
Province yeah I don't [ __ ] with fish
though I'm not worried about this my
home Province British Columbia has
supported Fish Farms despite the
well-documented scientists science
proving they are killing wild salmon
farm salmon are sub subjugated to many
diseases thus are loaded up with
antibiotics and Other Drugs one of the
problems are lice which cannot be
controlled in this environment just like
a Grade 3 classroom when Billy Jr shows
up with head lice
they have placed the farms in waters
that are in narrow protected inlets and
thus the wild young salmon past them
while leaving the rivers
yeah because this is all more profitable
to do it this way dude human beings are
just [ __ ] horrible these infested
Farms pass the lights on to the wild
salmon and the young salmon cannot
survive with a few lice our spawning
salmon rates are in great decline in
these areas there are several
contributing factors such as commercial
fishing and aboriginals having limited
restrictions
the governments like to blame the sports
fishermen yeah because they don't pay
them any money because it's an activity
that they're that are most that are
mostly wealthy white hetero old men
oh boy what are you doing here what are
you doing here
where are we going with this a group
that requires that carries a massive
Target on their back easy politics
now they don't blame they blame the
sports fishermen because they don't fund
their [ __ ] campaigns the way
commercial fishermen does
commercial Fisher is also run by wealthy
white men
oh boy I was wondering why you'd be
blaming the aboriginals having limited
restrictions yeah they're they're the
problem
commercial fishing and aboriginals
[Laughter]
amounts of antibiotics which then
results in the fish having immunity to
the antibiotics then the billionaire
Farm owners dump a drug called slice a
neurotoxin from the large boats which
kills most underwater Wildlife like a
nuclear bomb they are also using
hydrogen peroxide
these Farms are owned by a foreign
company based in Norway now called nawi
these Farms employ few people despite
the well-documented science they are
allowed to operate thanks to government
loopholes
um
unclear government agency okay agency
regulation between Fisheries Canada and
Canada's agriculture Ministry when a
responsible Minister begins to make a
change they are shuffled off to a new
ministry the Farms gained support by
several different First Nation bans
likely because of money it's all because
of money they're hereditary Chiefs many
line their own Pockets while educated
ones
juggle a confusing
all right
anyway
the fish escaping they can create a mute
mutant fish what are we doing
so stop eating farmed salmon if the
salmon you buy to store order at a
restaurant or as Sushi doesn't say while
it is pellet fish killing our wild
salmon thanks Bill well how do well
let's prevent some sushi restaurant or
any other restaurant to just say it's
wild when it isn't how am I going to
prove it
you can tell by the color man ah
whatever what do you got to do all right
um
then what then what I I go I go vegan
and then like
all of the vegetables are sprayed so
full of pesticides like I'll probably
get [ __ ] cancer I eat [ __ ] meat
it's cows that ate other cows
um
it's unfucking believable it's amazing
how none of these people get [ __ ] for
what the [ __ ] they're doing
you know I mean
we're living in a [ __ ] world where
you can literally poison the food supply
have nothing happen to you
but if you go on stage and tell the
wrong [ __ ] joke you can lose your
life
and say like your ability to [ __ ]
earn a living
um all right while shaving my will
shaving my head make me look like a
Neo-Nazi
hey
billipisha
uh I got my hair cut recently and The
Stylist told me my hair is very slightly
thinning at the crown I mentioned I'd
probably shave my head as soon as it's
noticeable to which The Stylist replied
I wouldn't recommend it you're so pale
that people might assume you're part of
the Aryan Brotherhood
yeah that also came from someone that
cuts hair for a living uh it's true I'm
a pasty Norwegian but I'm not going to
avoid shaving my head because of some
people's ignorant assumptions otherwise
the racist wind
uh what are your thoughts has anyone
ever accused you of being a white
supremacist because of your bald albino
ass no they haven't shaving your head
will not make you look like a Neo-Nazi
all right if you shave your head and
then [ __ ] you know put on a Nazi
armband
I think that that's what it'll be you
know
if you're standing there with a dad bod
and like flip-flops I don't think
they're thinking oh God
he's starting the fourth Reich over
there
um no actually if you keep yourself in
shape I feel and you shave your head
people will think you know some sort of
mixed martial arts
[Music]
[Laughter]
snakes that have the same coloring as a
poisonous snake so people think they're
poisonous but they're not really
poisonous yeah that's what I am
I'm like a gardener snake that looks
like a king snake uh
anyway plowing ahead uh oh speaking of
that I saw this [ __ ] um
speaking of mixed martial arts I saw
this clip of from The Joe Rogan
uh Experience Podcast where this dude
was talking about going into jail
in learning the different politics
of jail and all of that [ __ ] and this
guy actually
I I'm assuming had a mixed martial arts
background and was able to fight off
attackers and this guy told a [ __ ]
story
of finding out that there was basically
some
hit out on him
and he you know the guy in the cell next
to him told him
and I guess he knew that
that means his cellmate knew
you know because they tell the cellmate
to clear out of there whatever so the
[ __ ] next day the second the thing
opens the cellmate runs out and two guys
ran in to stab this guy up and he was
able to fight him off that's what I got
out of that whole thing
um aside from the fact that guards just
stand and watch fights
um
and sometimes organize them which is
[ __ ] Beyond barbaric
um you know I was in a good mood before
this [ __ ] podcast started I don't
know what's you know
is there any guys can let's let's we we
need to like cleanse here can we some
sort of good news have you heard
anything good out there
has somebody just taken time out of
their day to help somebody out did they
find the woman that [ __ ] chopped up
her boyfriend in three different they
[ __ ] found her yet can we get some
sort of rail light is there a place to
go where your food hasn't been [ __ ]
with
ah Jesus Christ can somebody just say
that the [ __ ] Astros cheated
um
anyway Jesus Christ
these [ __ ] guys
if they you know what's funny is they
just came out and said that they cheated
I would have rooted for the Astros
against the Yankees but the fact that
they didn't they actually had me rooting
for the [ __ ] New York Yankees
um see it's all connected man all right
anyway that's the podcast my daughter's
not feeling well so
I gotta go up there and I already start
to feel like this whole podcast if you
haven't noticed me clearing my throat
and [ __ ] hacking up like whatever she
has I think I'm starting to get it
uh
um so that's what I have to look forward
to this week
um but at least we're not sick on
Halloween you know we should be
hopefully good by then
all right that's the podcast
yeah I think I'm gonna go take a siesta
go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in on
you on Thursday